thank you all for being here and to
listen to my talk on IMF data Discovery
and extraction IMF is international
monetary fund and um a little bit about
me so my name is Irina Klein and I'm a
graduate student at Illinois tech
studying data science I'm very
passionate about data analysis and I
have a background in business data
analysis
so last summer I worked on a financial
data analysis project with Dr Sue Chang
Choi and we worked with IMF data and we
discovered that the current API for
automatic data extraction and
the underlying structure of the data
sets is quite complex especially for
unprepared users or non-technical users
such as economists or financial analysts
and
today I'd like to go over the data sets
available
in the IMF the current method for
automatic data extraction and how we
simplified this method in order to make
it more available
and this is a joint work with Dr
tsuching Choi
we'll cover the data sets available in
the international monetary fund we'll
look at the
current API for data extraction and then
we'll go
um
uh we'll go deeper into the um our
solution for um data extraction from the
IMF
so these are some of the data sets
available in the international monetary
fund and the international monetary fund
is in is an organization that provides
advising services to its member
countries and out of
195 countries in the world
190 are members of the
um IMF
um and from our apart from apart from
advising Services IMF collects data from
these countries and the data it collects
includes various
macroeconomic indices such as GDP
employment unemployment rates Consumer
Price indices and many others
and here's a list of some of the data
sets available on the IMF
um there are various methods to get this
data and the first one is the web query
interface which is an online tool to
have a quick overview of the um
of the indices where the user specifies
the time frame the countries they're
interested in and it's a it allows to
quickly evaluate what the um
what the index values are and there are
also some visualization tools it
provides then there is the bulk download
method which allows you to download a
CSV file with all the data and and
analyze large amounts of data however
um in order to update our new periods
that would have to be done manually
then there's the IMF data mapper which
is uh an online application and there's
also an app and they both work in the
same way so it's an online application
where you can see summary statistics and
some visualization of the data and again
this is a useful tool for a quick
overview of the situation some
comparisons between countries and
chronological Trends analysis and the
last method listed here is the Json
restful web service API which is a tool
for automatic data extraction
and it can be used with python or R and
the data that is downloaded is in the
format of Json files and
now um we'll look at each of these
methods in a little more detail so the
web query interface this is how it looks
and you could specify the time frame the
countries and the indicators you're
interested in
and see
um data in either tabular format or a
line chart
and here we have the GDP values for the
last five years for the US UK and
Germany
this is the bulk download method and for
each data set available you could click
on the little button next to it and this
would send a request to
um download that whole data set in bulk
um after the request is processed you
would get an email and then you would be
able to download the um
a zip file containing the CSV files with
the data and the metadata
um this is the IMF data mapper
um and it provides some visualization so
you could analyze either um
country to country or
um
the chronological trends of real GDP
and the last method we mentioned was the
Json restful web service API which is
used for automatic data extraction and
it downloads Json files so what is a
Json file it's a file format that allows
to efficiently that is used for
efficient
um transmission of data between web
applications and it consists of key
value Pairs and arrays an example of a
Json string is included here so this
string is taken from one of the imf's
data set the international financial
statistics data set or IFS
and as I said it can a Json string
consists of key value pairs so the key
is at value and the value as the string
AF and the next key is description and
the value is
another so-called nested map structure
also consisting of key value Pairs and
the description shows us that this
string AF stands for the country name
Afghanistan
and rest
um and restful API is a interface to
interact with resources on the web using
the so-called rest design pattern and it
allows to efficiently
um
for resources on the web to interact
efficiently and in a standardized way so
the user
um can send a request to a server to
read some data and then the server the
server would send a response back
and there are some examples of how to
use imf's Json restful web service API
um online additional examples are
provided in my GitHub repository and the
link to the GitHub repository will be
shown
a little later
um
so before we go before we look into
examples there are some useful
definitions that we should cover in the
IMF series refers to the data set for
example the international financial
statistics data set or ifs is a serious
name
um indicator refers to the economic
index or metric for example GDP
and dimension refers to the metadata of
of an indicator so it's a way to
categorize values so for example GDP
um
the dimensions are
area or the country us the frequency for
example quarterly gep and the period for
example
of the quarterly gep for 2020.
um there are also some other useful
definitions that we should mention
before moving on to examples so metadata
as I said
um it's a set of data that describes
other data
um we'll also talk about python packages
which is a collection of installable
reusable python code
where um a user can
install the package and use it for a
specific task a data frame is a
two-dimensional and tabular format
Independence data frame is a data frame
created with a with the python with the
pandas python package
now we'll
talk a little more about the
um Jason Russell web service API that's
used for automatic data extraction from
the IMF as I said it loads Json files
and this is how a Json file could be
visualized so here we have an example of
metadata structure in the gifsr
um
data set which is government financial
statistics Revenue data set and this is
the area dimension
um we can see on the top here that the
dimension ID is CL area gfsr and the
dimension name on the left is
geographical areas then
um each country code is listed and for
each country code we are given a
description of what country it stands
for
add an example of how data is structured
um
in the imf's Json files so on the top we
have some metadata the frequency the
country and the indicator code
and at the bottom here
um the observations are given as a list
um so these are real GDP values for each
time step in the year of 2022.
um now we'll look at an example of how
this data could be exported using the
Json restful API
and we'll analyze the quarterly change
in Real GDP for the US and in order to
do that with the Json restful API the
user must know the structure of the
underlying data set what the dimensions
are
and how to access them and also specify
the necessary Dimensions so for example
the index code that we're interested in
the country codes that we're interested
in and then
knowing that the user would request data
using the compact data method there are
various methods
um
available to interact with the Json
restful web service API will not be
covering those in detail
because
um
later I'll show an example of how this
process could be simplified however in
the GitHub repository there is a
description of each method
now let's look at an example of how this
data could be accessed
using the the API
so
this is a python notebook
and first we import the necessary
libraries we specify the series that
we're interested in the frequency and
the country code and the time frame
using the data structure method we will
search for indices related to GDP
and then this cell here
outputs the all the indices that are
related to GDP again I won't be going
into the specifics of how it works but
um the user must know the structure of
the data set
in order to access this data
so this is the list of the um index
codes and their description we are
interested in the real GDP seasonally
adjusted in domestic currency so we
specify this code here
then using this compact data method we
send a request to the IMF server to
retrieve this data and then we process
it and turn it into a pandas data frame
so
this is the output this is the output
data frame
having done that we can now analyze the
quarter on quarter change using the
pandas percent change function
and after that we can plot this data
using matplotlib
and here's the results and we can
observe the real GDP Trend
um
going upwards and with the
dip here in the second quarter of 2020
most likely related to the pandemic
and then we save this data frame to a
CSV file
um so this is an example of how Json
restful API is used to retrieve data and
analyze data the user
I must not only know the um the
structure of the data set but also
understand well the
index codes and the country codes that
need to be specified in order to
retrieve it and given that the structure
of these data sets varies from series to
series it might be too complex for an
unprepared user and it would require a
lot of time to understand the different
dimensions and how to access this data
so there has been work on
um on making this process simpler and
there's a number of packages that were
created in order to um
hide these complexities from the user
and the first one the IMF data r package
it allows to search through series and
index codes and output data giving
series names in given index codes and
other parameters it is however not
actively maintained
the second data Punchy IMF package it
allows to allow data and metadata
um
given index codes any and other
parameters again
um
however it's not very intuitive and
there's very little documentation
provided
the IMF Pi package it allows to
efficiently search through the data sets
and the index codes and download data
for the direction of trade statistics
into pandas data frames and visualize it
the pi IMF package also allows to search
through data sets and index codes
however it doesn't install correctly and
there's very little documentation and
the last package mentioned here is
our solution to the problem outline
before which I'll talk now in in more
detail
so the IMF data Pi package we propose
creating this a wrapper package that
would mask the complexities of the Json
restful API and it would provide an
intuitive way to search through index
index names so that the user would
wouldn't have to know the index codes
and specify those in the request
the package
should have a detailed and searchable
documentation and the functionality
should be insured with unit tests
because as I said the structure varies
from series to Series so one approach
might not work for another data set
the current work on the package is
released in this GitHub repository
and
the package is structured in an
object-oriented way with child classes
inheriting functionality from parent
classes so each um
a child object is a series and this way
we can efficiently keep the same
functionality for the series where the
structure of the data set is similar and
adjust the methods for those data sets
where the structure of the underlying
Json files is different
um to install this package the user
would have to run the PIP install
command and now we'll look at an example
of how to extract real GDP quarter on
quarter change using the IMF data Pi
package so it's the same example we
looked at before only with the package
so first we install the package using
pip install
then we import it and we also import
pandas in order to um for the percent
change function in order to analyze the
quarter on quarter change
and now
instead of specifying the index code the
user has to input a search term so for
example we know that we are interested
in GDP so we specify that string here
and then using the download data method
all the data
that where the index code where the
index matches our search term will be
downloaded so the resulting data frame
contains values for all indices related
to GDP
and this way the user wouldn't have to
um
first of all understand the structure of
the Json files and second of all I'll
look know the specific index codes which
are shown here on the right
um since we know that
since um
so as I said all the all the all the
different indices related to GDP are
downloaded and in order to view what
which
um which indices
we've downloaded we can look into the
metadata file that's also downloaded
with the download
method and we know that we're interested
in real seasonally adjusted GDP so we
filter our data frame to contain just
the real GDP
we then visualize it we then perform the
percent change function to analyze the
quarter on quarter change and we
visualize it in the same way using
matplotlib
um
so we've designed an extensible software
um with the IMF data Pi package in order
to
discover and extract IMF data and
the ongoing work includes creating
comprehensible documentation
implementing robust in parsing and
testing the package with the unit tests
for each series because as I said the
structure of the of different series is
different
we also will also add a summary and
descriptive statistics for the data sets
that are loaded so that the user could
um and could have a better understanding
of what kind of data is loaded and
um
and also we are interested in collecting
more economic and financial use cases
using IMF data pi
um these are some of the
these are our sources
and
thank you for the attention
um
I'd like
um I'd also like to say that I hope that
um this package and the future
improvements would help
um
Economist and financial analysts or or
anyone interested in working with
macroeconomic data
to um have an easier access to it and to
make it more available the
um
um the GitHub repository is shown here
and also the pi page where you could um
where you could um see how to install
the package
um if you have any questions please let
me know
and feel free to send me an email if you
have any suggestions or questions on how
to work with the package or about the
IMF data in general